on fait la fois suivi les épisodes car
[Musique]
vous l'aurez schéma quatrième séances de
détatouage au laser pour essayer de
faire partir si la nation et fès pour
ceux qui n'ont pas suivi les épisodes
précédents
je vous propose un petit résumé jean
marie fesse gauche ya maintenant presque
10 mois de ça j'ai eu l'idée de vous
faire une vidéo sur le tatouage et je me
suis dit que le mieux c'était quand même
de la faire dans les conditions du réel
donc je suis allé me faire tatouer et je
vous expliquer les pourquoi du comment
du tatouage
suite à ça je me suis retrouvé avec
cyril hanouna tatoué sur le cul et je me
suis dit que c'était une bonne idée de
vous faire une vidéo sur le détatouage
donc j'ai pris rendez-vous dans un
centre de laser que la technique de le
plus adapté à mon cas et j'ai fait un
certain nombre de séances voilà qu'au
départ le médecin m'a dit on part sur
six séances
les séances s'enchaînent avec deux mois
d'intervalle entre chaque
et il s'avère qu'aujourd'hui mon
tatouage qui au départ ressembler à ça
maintenant il ressemble à ça c'est à
dire que bon le résultat est pour
l'instant assez discret aujourd'hui
voilà partis pour la quatrième séance
sur six donc enfin a priori et c'est
vrai que j'y vais avec une petite
appréhension puisque comme on vient de
le voir c'est pas très probant pour le
moment la dernière fois le médecin m'a
dit qu'il allait changer de longueur
d'onde puisque le laser c'est des
longueurs d'onde qui correspondent à des
couleurs donc là aujourd'hui il va
tenter autre chose après avoir
progressivement augmenter la puissance
et donc la douleur pour le moment le
médecin il reste assez confiant donc moi
aussi parce que c'est lui professionnel
après tout mais quand je vous ai croisé
dans des conventions par exemple ou dans
la rue la première question que vous me
posez c'est alors c'en est où est la
deuxième question qui vient
immédiatement après quand je vous
explique que ça on est pas
c'est est ce que tu penses pas à flipper
non je commence pas à flipper mais je
vais quand même lui poser la question
aujourd'hui savoir si il est vraiment
toujours aussi confiant et si ils
envisagent pas éventuellement que ça
pourrait prendre plus de temps que prévu
donc je vous tiens au courant après la
séance comme d'habitude je vous emmène
avec moi c'est parti
[Musique]
oui avant je vais passer chez le
coiffeur parce que c'est important
d'être présent tu as quand même dans ces
conditions minimum
[Musique]
comme vous pouvez voir le coiffeur c'est
fait donc maintenant j'ai plus qu'à il
est allé
[Musique]
son père
voilà c'est fini alors comme vous l'avez
eue balle ça fait encore plus mal que
les fois précédentes
et ça c'était un petit peu attendu je
l'expliqué ça après et puis surtout j'ai
moyer en bonne nouvelle pour être là je
rentre chez moi je me pose et je vous
explique tout ça alors donc comme prévu
ça fait plus mal que d'habitude il n'a
pas fait une longueur d'onde différentes
contrairement ce qui m'a donné la foi il
ajuste élargi le faisceau c'est à dire
que c'était plus large cet appel plus
large sur ma peau que les fois
précédentes
donc ça fait un peu plus mal et donc
comme prévu
je lui ai posé la question de savoir
s'il était toujours aussi confiant et là
j'ai eu une bonne nouvelle et une
mauvaise nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que oui il est
toujours aussi confiant la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est qui m'a avoué que
vraisemblablement six séances ça ne
suffira pas et qui tapait plutôt sur
minimum 10 c'est à dire que quatre
séances de plus avec deux mois
d'intervalle entre chaque on est parti
sur huit mois de plus et sur quatre
séances où ça va bien piqué pascal a
priori j'imagine qu'il va continuer à
booster un petit peu le truc à chaque
fois pour répondre à la question que
vous me posez souvent est-ce que je
commence à flipper non parce qu'après
tout c'est sur ma fait c'est ma façon la
voit pas tous les quatre matins à tout
le monde en tout cas et puis surtout si
ça marche pas j'essaierai d'autres
moyens au pire je le ferai à recouvrir
c'est pas forcément un truc que j'avais
prévu d'avoir un tatouage sur le cube
est bon au pire tu peux m'en sortir
et concernant la deuxième question à
savoir est ce que je regrette parce que
oui la question se pose effectivement
ben non je regrette pas parce qu'en fait
si j'avais fait la vidéo en vous disant
voilà un tatouage ça se passe comme ça
le laser ça se passe comme ça on fait
six séances et puis après c'est terminé
bah aurait menti en fait là le double
avantage c'est que 1
je suis vraiment très bien placé pour
vous dire que ça fait très mal et puis
surtout vous pouvez voir que ça se passe
pas aussi bien que prévu
à chaque fois et que parfois il faut
rajouter des séances donc
pédagogiquement il ya un vrai intérêt au
fait de tester vraiment sur moi même je
vraiment vous dire voilà comment ça se
passe voilà comment on sait prévu que ça
se passe et voilà comment ça se passe en
réalité donc moralité bas réfléchissez
peut-être un tout petit peu avant de
vous faire un tatouage et puis bon parce
que vous êtes des petits curieux que
vous voulez voir de vos propres yeux ce
qui se passe donc voilà à quoi ça
ressemble là c'est le tatouage
quelques heures après la séance de laser
là c'est le tatouage le lendemain et là
c'est le tatouage deux jours après voilà
comme vous l'avez compris on est parti
pour quelques mois supplémentaires je
sais pas si je vous ferai des vidéos à
chaque fois dites moi dans les
commentaires si ça vous intéresse ou pas
en attendant on se retrouve très vite
pour une prochaine vidéo
d'ici là bas comme le veut la coutume
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]